ich bereue zutiefst wenn ich durch mein
Verhalten in Bezug auf das in Rede
stehende Pamphlet oder der weitere
Vorwürfe gegen mich aus der Jugendzeit
Gefühle verletzt habe meine aufrichtige
Entschuldigung gilt zuvor dass allen
Opfern des Ines Regimes deren
Hinterbliebenen und allen Beteiligten
und der wertvollen Erinnerungsarbeit
ja war das jetzt der Befreiungsschlag
für Hubert Aiwanger um im Amt zu bleiben
entschuldigt hat er sich aber die
Urheberschaft des ebenso unsäglichen wie
unerträglichen Flugblattes die leugnet
er weiterhin ob Markus Söder jetzt
zufrieden ist die vielen noch
ungeklärten Fragen zu den Ereignissen
vor 36 Jahren lassen da Zweifel
aufkommen
klar im Wahlkampf der Fall Aiwanger
jetzt in der Phönix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Frau Professorin Sabine kroppes bei uns
Politikwissenschaftlerin an der Freien
Universität Berlin schwerpunkt ist das
Thema politisches System der
Bundesrepublik Alexander Kain ist hier
stellvertretender Chefredakteur der
Passauer Neuen Presse nicht weit weg von
der Gegend in der Hubert Albaner
aufgewachsen ist die Passauer Neue
Presse gehört zur Mediengruppe Bayern
Christoph von Marschall ist
diplomatischer Korrespondent der
Chefredaktion des Tagesspiegel hier in
Berlin
und bei uns ist der
Kommunikationswissenschaftler Olaf
Hoffmann Professor für
Organisationskommunikation und
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit an der Universität
Bamberg Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer sie haben am Eingang der
Sendung diese Äußerung von von Hubert
Aiwanger gehört er hat bei diesem
Statement die das nur wenige Stunden alt
ist aber allerdings auch noch andere
Punkte angesprochen und die zeigen wir
Ihnen jetzt
die Vorwürfe haben mich erschreckt ich
kann mich nicht erinnern jemals einen
Hitlergruß gezeigt zu haben ich habe
keine Hitler reden vor dem Spiegel
einstudiert weitere Vorwürfe wie
menschenfeindliche Witze kann ich aus
meiner Erinnerung wieder vollständig
dementieren noch bestätigen sollte dies
geschehen sein so entschuldige ich mich
dafür in aller Form es ist jedoch nicht
akzeptabel dass diese Verfehlungen jetzt
in einer politischen Kampagne gegen mich
und meine parteiinstrumentalisiert
werden ich habe den Eindruck ich soll
politisch und persönlich fertig gemacht
werden es ist ein negatives Bild von mir
in den letzten Tagen gezeichnet worden
das bin nicht ich das ist nicht Huberti
soweit ist es statementfragen waren
nicht zugelassen der Pressesprecher der
Freien Wähler hat noch erwähnt dass
zeitnah auch die 25 Fragen beantwortet
werden ja es geht ja um Einsicht es geht
um Glaubwürdigkeit es geht um
amtswürdigkeit ja auch er ist Minister
wie ist dieses Statement zu werden
sie können anfangen pro Kopf ich denke
diese Erklärung wäre gefällig gewesen
unmittelbar nach bekannt werden der
Vorwürfe oder aber als er mit den
Vorwürfen konfrontiert worden ist im
Vorfeld der Veröffentlichung hätte
Hubert Aiwanger gesagt ich habe in
meiner Jugend zum Beispiel dieses und
jenes begangen oder auch nicht er
bestreitet es ja und hätte er den Bruder
vielleicht nicht nachgeschoben was man
nicht nachweisen kann aber irgendeine
Erklärung im Vorfeld die die
rolleiwangers klargestellt hätte wäre
sinnvoll gewesen stattdessen hat der
depurerwürfelpauschal zurückgewiesen und
damit eine Diskussion ermöglicht die er
jetzt auch nicht mehr einfangen kann
also unbeschadet der Tatsache dass man
zutrifft oder nicht also fertig gemacht
werden behauptet er am Schluss dieses
Statements da wird ein Bild von ihm
gezeichnet das nicht Hubert Albaner ist
wie muss man das jetzt im Umfeld dessen
was wir vor allem seit gestern auch
wissen Sie noch zusätzliche
Informationen dazugekommen werden naja
stand auch Informationen dazu gekommen
dass viele Klassenkameraden sich nicht
erinnern können dass der Hubert so ein
latentrechter Bursche gewesen wäre es
war überhaupt die Frage was ist jetzt
der Erkenntnisgewinn aus dieser
Geschichte die vor 36 Jahren
stattgefunden hat macht uns oder bringt
uns deshalb den den Hubert einwanger von
heute dann wirklich näher das Hubert
Aiwanger einer ist der unangepasst ist
dass er einer ist der bisweilen auch
populistisch unterwegs ist dass er einer
ist der auch sehr konservativ unterwegs
ist das muss man alles vorher also was
ist der Erkenntnisgewinn aus einer
Geschichte die vor 35 oder 36 Jahren im
geschützten raumschule stattgefunden hat
ja was ist der Erkenntnisgewinn
die so oft bei solchen Dingen wird am
Ende nicht darum gehen was damals war
sondern wie man heute damit umgeht und
wie Hubert einfacher heute damit umgeht
da lernen wir schon etwas über ihn ich
glaube wir müssen mal trennen die
Perspektiven es gibt etwas so sich alle
einigen können ganz egal wo sie
politisch stehen das ist ein widerliches
Pamphlet niemand verteidigt das
es gibt auch fast niemanden der sagt na
ja
bei solchen Äußerungen muss man bei
Minderjährigen nicht so genau hinschauen
sondern wenn überhaupt ist doch der
Vorwurf dass hier nicht redlich mit der
Sache umgegangen worden ist also muss es
für die politische Beurteilung eines
52-Jährigen interessieren was vor 36
Jahren in der Schule gewesen ist ja oder
nein und ich glaube die meisten
Deutschen denken eher nein unbeschadet
der Tatsache dass alle sagen dass es
widerlich was in diesem Vertreter drin
steht und über eine Sache glaube ich
können sich die Leute und das ist leider
ein Kennzeichen unserer Zeit nicht
einigen je nachdem wo man selbst
politisch steht ich würde jetzt mal
sagen Stadtbewohner links der Mitte
haben vermutlich wesentlich mehr
Sympathie für die Rücktrittsforderung
und wenn ich mir vorstelle die Bayern
die dabei im Hubert Aiwanger auf dem
Dorf leben die werden wahrscheinlich in
ganz großer Mehrheit sagen das ist
völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist völlig
unverhältnismäßig wegen so etwas den
Rücktritt zu fördern ich glaube der die
Sache ist nicht gegessen zum Rücktritt
kann es immer noch kommen aber wenn es
zu dem Rücktritt kommt dann wegen
Umgangs von Aiwanger jetzt und nicht
weil irgendwie die erdrückende Mehrheit
der Deutschen das Gefühl hätte man muss
das was vor 35 Jahren im Alter von 17
Jahren in der Schule war oder nicht war
auf die Goldwaage legen jetzt legen wir
hoffen leben wir ja in einer
Mediengesellschaft sich auch ganz schön
erregen kann da geht es ja auch um
Kommunikation auch in diesem ganzen
Umfeld dass er schon gehört haben
Befürworter Ablehner Leute die das an
die große Glocke hängen wollen Leute die
sagen das ist alles völlig unnötig in
diesem Feld muss ich auch ein Politiker
wie Hubert einwanger bewegen und das
kann er ja offensichtlich auch er war ja
bisher relativ erfolgreich
aus Sicht des Kommunikationsmanagements
der Art und Weise der
Kommunikationsstrategie hat er sich
bisher klug verhalten oder ist das alles
noch verbesserungsbedürftig
verbesserungsbedürftig kann es immer
sein das ist klar ich würde sagen also
bis vorgestern hatte es eigentlich noch
recht gut gemacht gestern hat er sich um
Kopf und Kragen geredet und heute hat er
finde ich eigentlich ein erstaunlichen
Fehler gemacht denn er hat nämlich zwei
krisenkommunikationsstrategie
miteinander verbunden die man eigentlich
nicht miteinander verbinden sollte denn
er hat sich entschuldigt und er hat
angegriffen und beides gleichzeitig ist
passt eigentlich nicht zusammen am
Anfang einer Krise sollte man sich
entscheiden was man machen möchte er hat
sich damals für den Angriff entschieden
er hat sich in der Opferrolle gesehen
und ich hätte sogar bis vorgestern auch
geglaubt dass es auch gut gehen kann da
hat ihm Söder glaube ich sehr viele
Brücken gebaut seit gestern und auch
seit heute glaube ich der weniger dran
und würde eben auch sehen wie er jetzt
auch mit der Krise umgeht das kann jetzt
erst recht gefährlich für ihn werden wie
geht das
Wissen dazu auch dieser Charakter Hubert
Aiwanger ist natürlich ein ganz
spezieller Krawatte Charakter das ist
nicht einer der der zurecht geschliffen
ist für dieses Berliner Parkett sondern
das ist einer der nicht über jedes
stöckerl hüpft dass man ihn im hinhält
und ja das im Zweifelsfall auch mehr
aussteht so hat er jetzt 20 Jahre
Politik gemacht dass er Dinge auch mehr
aussteht dass er Dinge auf den Punkt
bringt wie er das denkt und dass er sich
nicht immer erklärt wenn andere sagen du
musst dich erklären und so hat das ja
auch bei der Süddeutschen gehandelt
gehalten als die ihm einen Fragenkatalog
hingelegt hat zentral in diesem
Fragenkatalog war der Vorwurf er habe
damals dieses Pamphlet verfasst
und da ist der Bruder da der sagt nö das
war ich ich kann mir vorstellen wie der
Huber in so einer Situation der sagt ich
habe das nicht geschrieben dann lasse
ich die Süddeutsche Zeitung jetzt ins
Leerlauf ein Kommunikationsprofi
ihr das Kalibers würde sagen nein das
musst du ganz anders machen aber sonst
auf seiner Sicht bodenständiger
Politiker wieder Hubert Albaner der
tickt da völlig anders und der springt
eben nicht über diese das heißt der hat
sich da auf seinen Bauch verlassen die
Frage ist ob das klug war ist es
eigentlich noch so wichtig rauszukriegen
ob er es war oder sein Bruder das wird
man vielleicht gar nicht mehr rausfinden
können oder ich glaube oder müssen also
das glaube ich ist letztlich eben auch
nicht der Grund für den Rücktritt aber
ich würde dann doch ein bisschen die
Sache noch differenzieren wollen denn
wenn 2008 glaube ich bereits die Anfrage
in der Schule über eine Parteikollegin
oder eine Kollegin der Freien Wähler
erfolgt ob da denn irgendwie was
rauskommen könnte zeigt ja das Hubert
Aiwanger der Sache sich bewusst war dass
es kommen könnte und dann in dieser
konkreten Situation so zu reagieren das
wird doch dann sehr zusammengestoppelt
und die Plausibilität dessen was davor
getragen wurde die ist relativ gering
die faktische nach Belastbarkeit ist
etwas anderes aber die Plausibilität ist
denke ich in den vergangenen fünf Tagen
sukzessive nach unten gegangen also vor
15 Jahren hat es diese Anfrage ich
glaube es war es war eine Parteifreundin
aber nicht in der Schule sondern bei
einem der Lehrer von Hubert Aiwanger
gewesen die ja dort auch noch mal
angerufen hat nachdem jetzt diese neuen
Vorwürfe hochgekommen sind
offenbar schon seit längerer Zeit immer
wieder mal damit hausieren geht und das
Ding loswerden möchten
2018 auch schon mal davon erzählt ja ich
wollte nur sagen ich finde nicht dass
das unbedeutend ist wäre es war also
wenn raus wenn bewiesen werden könnte
das Hubert Albaner das geschrieben hat
dann ist das eine glatte Lüge und dann
ist die Sache gelaufen also dann
wahrscheinlich ja gut ich wollte nur ich
hatte dann habe ich vielleicht falsch
verstanden nicht mehr drauf an doch es
kommt drauf an also wenn man es
nachweisen kann wäre das der
eklatanteste Grund warum man so
zurücktreten muss
nicht so sicher ob der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Köder in wirklich
Brücken baut also der ist ja in der
schwierigen Situation er darf jetzt
sozusagen nicht selber noch
beckmesserischer oder noch härter als
die Süddeutsche mit seinem Vize umgehen
und auf der anderen Seite darf man
natürlich auch nicht zu viel Verständnis
zeigen und hat auch gar kein politisches
Interesse zu viel Verständnis zu zeigen
diese 25 Fragen damit will der Zeit
gewinnen und hat den Druck auf Wanger
unheimlich erhöht da muss ja nur
irgendwas rauskommen dass bei einer
dieser Antworten die eine der anderen
widerspricht und schon hat er hat den
jetzt so richtig schön unter Druck aber
halt eine ganz andere Frage ist wie die
Leute draußen reagieren und da bin ich
noch mal den Punkt Mann ich glaube eben
dass die in unterschiedlichen Gegenden
sehr unterschiedlich reagieren und
deswegen ist dieser grad auf dem Söder
balanciert sehr sehr schmal weil er sich
entweder mit den Einen oder mit den
anderen weniger Wochen vor der Wahl
verscherzen könnte wenn er dazu hat
umgeht und das einfach ist für ihn
natürlich hat er auch schon angeboten er
würde halt auch mit den Freien Wählern
weiter koalieren ohne an Aiwanger und ob
die sich dann sagen das wäre ein Grund
die Koalition nicht vorzuführen da bin
ich mir auch nicht so sicher
also der Grad für Söder ist sicherlich
mal der ist sicherlich in der Defensive
dass sehe ich ganz genauso allerdings
was ich schon beeindruckend fand das war
hohe politische Kunst das war die
Pressekonferenz meines Erachtens weil da
ist reden von Markus so dass am Montag
am Dienstag glaube ich die
Pressekonferenz weil da ist es ihm
gelungen einerseits das Heft des
Handelns wieder in die Hand zu nehmen er
hat sich da als starker Mann präsentiert
der seinen Stellvertreter mal 25 Fragen
mitgibt wie so ein Lehrer einem
unartigen Schüler aber vor allem ist es
eben meines Erachtens gelungen
sogenannte strategische Ambiguität
mehrdeutig zu reden das heißt egal wie
es jetzt ausgeht am Ende steht Söder
nicht als derjenige da der verloren
hätte wenn er ihn behält also ich sie
schon dass er ihm die ein oder andere
Brücke gebaut hat dann ist es okay wenn
er ihn entlassen muss er hat gesagt es
darf jetzt nichts mehr kommen dann hat
er auch am Ende recht behalten und wenn
er geht und kann man weiter mit den
Freien Wählern arbeiten das hat er ja
eben auch gesagt das wäre für ihn
natürlich am Ende der Joker und der
Hauptgewinn den er gewinnen könnte
starker Mann präsentieren möchte das
haben wir übrigens schon er hat so
verlauten lassen man habe den Aiwanger
einbestellt zum Koalitionsausschuss ins
Kabinett kann er als Ministerpräsident
einbestellen weil da ist ja der Chefin
und Koalitionsausschuss ist einer von
zwei Partnern da hat er nichts
einzubestellen aber da wollte er schon
nach außen genau dieses Bild abliefern
aber noch mal was ich ganz interessant
finde was war denn der Beginn dieser
ganzen Affäre der Beginn war die
Unterstellung Aiwanger habe
dieses Papier verfasst das war der
Beginn dieser ganzen Geschichte und zwei
Tage später lesen wir in der
Süddeutschen der Glaube schon den Bruder
es kommen gar nicht mehr drauf an ob es
verfasst habe
es hat sich mittlerweile in so großer
Strauß an Dingen ergeben
Aiwanger müsse zurücktreten das ist
natürlich die Frage wie wir mit solchen
Krisen auch journalistisch mittlerweile
umgehen es ist ja ein fröhliches Halali
wer findet denn jetzt irgendwas in der
Geschichte aiwangers dass man jetzt
deuten kann das sind jetzt da mit
einbringen kann also würde ich gleich
gerne drauf eingehen vielleicht eine
halbe Schritt zurück kriegst du von
Marschall
es ist ja ein bekanntes framing und ein
Bekannter Vorgang das ist nicht zum
ersten Mal passiert das in einem
Wahlkampf wo es hat zur Sache geht
plötzlich einen etwas belastendes für
einen der Beteiligten den Wahlkämpfer
auftaucht so ziemlich passend vorm
Wahltermin das hat jetzt viele auch
stutzig gemacht selbst wenn es da schon
eine Vorgeschichte gibt dass ich Albaner
selbst erkundigt haben soll dass man
natürlich auch auf Albaner wie in dieser
Äußerungen Erding dass man sich die
Demokratie zurückholen soll natürlich
schon besonders im Fokus war aber es
fällt natürlich schon auf das sechs
Wochen vor der Fall so etwas plötzlich
in einer breiten Öffentlichkeit und zwar
nicht nur in Bayern sondern ganz
Deutschland diskutiert wird ja also ich
bin da natürlich jetzt ein bisschen auch
eingeübt durch meine Zeit in den USA da
ist das absolut üblich das weiß auch
jeder vorher dass die Gegenseite
sogenanntes attac-material sammeln nicht
und auch nicht dann wenn sie es hat es
rausgibt sondern sich für den möglichst
günstigsten Zeitpunkt aufbewahrt also
etwas was man im April weiß wird man
dann trotzdem jetzt im Oktober drei
Wochen Urlaub
hier ist dieser Mechanismus vertraut und
ich glaube der ist auch inzwischen in
der deutschen Politik angekommen und
wird nicht per se als die legitimiert
betrachtet sondern es ist eine Frage der
Überzeugung ist das nur relevant ist es
nicht relevant ist das ähm legitim das
aufzubewahren und zum günstigen
Zeitpunkt zu kommen oder nicht ich
glaube so wird das mehr betrachten das
ist vom Einzelfall her zu betrachten wir
haben hier wir haben hier einen
richtigen Streit um die Glaubwürdigkeit
und Überzeugung nicht also die
Süddeutsche Zeitung unsere Kollegen dort
die haben jetzt schwere Beschwerden beim
presserad Laufen weil halt doch fanden
wie das gemacht worden ist es halt eine
bestimmte Anklage zusammengetragen
worden man hatte nicht den Eindruck dass
auf entlastende oder doppeldeutige Dinge
besonders Wert gelegt wurde ob man die
so rum oder so rum sehen kann und dabei
ist die Frage der schafft ja nur eine
dieser Fragen und ich denke deswegen ist
es auch eine Frage an uns Medien sie
haben das gesagt wie man wie man damit
umgeht was legitim ist und was nicht und
was mir persönlich unangenehm
aufgefallen ist man hat ja versucht so
eine zeitliche gerade wenn dir als
17-Jähriger was gemacht hat und heute
ist er Rechtspopulist einmal Nazi immer
Nazi und das geht halt eine Spur zu weit
Hubert einwanger ist in den letzten
Jahren nicht als jemand aufgefallen der
bei passenden oder unpassen
Gelegenheiten irgendwas Nazi
verdächtiges gesagt der die damalige
Regierung verteidigt oder die Autobahnen
gut findet weil sie von Hitler gebaut
worden sind nichts dergleichen und
deswegen und auch nicht antisemitisch
und das macht diese Sache so ein
bisschen unangenehm
dass man den Eindruck hatte sollte so
eine Verbindung hergestellt werden für
die ist eigentlich in den letzten Jahren
womöglich gibt's diese Verbindung glaube
ich stand in diesem Artikel wir haben
auch einen Kollegen oder einen Kollegen
der Situation gebeten die Sendung zu
kommen wir hatten dann von der
chefreaktion des deutschen Zeitung
allerdings die Mitteilung bekommen dass
im Moment niemand in die Sendung kommt
und damit ich diskutiert das nehmen wir
jetzt einfach so hin und muss auch
akzeptiert werden
was da veröffentlicht worden ist das
waren ja das sind Zeitzeugen die sind im
Moment noch anonymisiert das ist kein
unübliches Verfahren um Zeugen zu
schützen nur bei einer
Gerichtsverhandlung müsste man daraus
und Reiter nennen die ich glaube einige
haben sogar eine alte stadtliche
Erklärung abgegeben jeden Lehrer sind
Mitschüler sind bekannte aus dem ganzen
Umfeld von von Hubert einwanger ist das
denn journalistische Kommunisten Pflicht
was wir jetzt gerade da erleben oder ist
es doch ein massiver Eingriff in den
Wahlkampf ja das ist natürlich es ist
ein Eingriff in gewisser Weise weil es
den Wahlkampf doch mutmaßlich wie wir
sehen beeinflusst aber ich sehe schon
das ist normales politisches
Tagesgeschäft und die Frage ist ja dann
am Ende auch wenn man jetzt die
Süddeutsche Zeitung bewertet ist es
legitim darüber zu bewerten also waren
die Information hat und wenn man sich
das anschaut dann sehe ich jetzt also
diese Frage der Autorenschaft die ihr
aber ja die Süddeutsche Zeitung ja auch
nicht behauptet hat sie hat sie
vielleicht suggeriert in Frage gestellt
der Unterschied zwischen Indizien und
beweisen genau und alle anderen Dinge
haben sich ja bestätigt an der Stelle
also von daher ist das schon
es ist legitim und und auch angemessen
darüber zu schreiben und da finde ich
dann eben auch so eine Reaktion ich bin
jetzt beleidigt ich bin das
Opfer das mag ja eben in seinem Wesen
vielleicht angegelegt sein dass er eben
dann so reagiert so stark aber es ist
unprofessionell und hat jetzt an der
Stelle eben auf dem Kunden nicht
aufzuprobieren geführt der Beginn einer
hat also wenn ich mir vorstelle dass ein
Klassenfoto das 16 oder 17-Jährigen
Hubert aiwangers veröffentlicht wurde wo
man ihn sieht wo man jetzt nicht sagen
kann ist das Bad Pflaumen oder ist es
ein Hitler Bärchen ist ein Unterschied
ob der schwarz-weiß oder farbig gezeigt
wurde ich ich finde das auf dem farbig
sieht man das glauben ist
sieht so aus wie ein hitlerbärchen
Märchen und unten Scheitel sind wir
jetzt soweit dass wir versuchen auf
Klassenfotos als Indiz zu sagen das ist
ein Nazi also wo führt uns diese Art der
Berichterstattung hin und es am Anfang
stand ein Verdacht und die große Zeile
mit Verlaub die Urheberschaft ist schon
ganz wichtig denn das hat die
Süddeutsche auf die Seite 1 geschrieben
er soll verfasst haben damit war die
Tonalität des ganzen gesetzt er soll
verfasst haben das war am Samstag in der
Früh groß auf der gedruckten
Süddeutschen Zeitung und am Samstag
Nachmittag war das geplatzt weil der
Bruder gesagt hat nö ich weiß diese
Diskussion diese öffentliche Diskussion
im politischen System der Bundesrepublik
ihr wissenschaftliches Leib und
Marketing Thema welche Rolle spielt
diese die Öffentlichkeit manche
unterscheiden ja auch zwischen
öffentlichen Diskussion oder oder
öffentlichen Meinung und
veröffentlichter Meinung wie muss man
das gerade an diesem Beispiel sehen
nun ja also die öffentliche Meinung
spielt natürlich eine Rolle also zumal
in Wahlkampfzeiten und vielleicht noch
einen Punkt der mir an dem er auch etwas
liegt also diese diese Abwehrhaltung
diese täteropfer umkehrt dieser Versuch
also sofort sie sagen beleidigt zu sein
das hängt natürlich auch mit der Rolle
der Freien Wähler und dem
anti-parteien-effekt den sie pflegen
zusammen natürlich sind sie auch Partei
wir haben parteistatus wenn sie im
Landtag eintreten aber gleichzeitig ist
diese rebellische Haltung nach außen
getragen etwas was man in der
Öffentlichkeit gerade in Bayern was
zieht auf der einen Seite wie hat er
überzogen in den letzten Wochen und
jetzt auch ich denke diese diese
Umkehr ist gerade mit dem Thema in
Verbindung mit dem Thema Holocaust etwas
was im Wahlkampf gefährlich ist also was
dazu führt dass es solidaritätseffekte
gibt auf der einen Seite wie auf der
anderen Seite und dieses Thema ist dafür
eigentlich denkbar ungeeignet oder
sollte ungeeignet sein und da sehe ich
auch auch in der Frage der
Öffentlichkeit und der Frage der
Mobilisierung zwischen unterschiedlichen
Gruppen in der Öffentlichkeit in dem
Wahlkampf ein Problem das heißt dass das
Thema Holocaust und wieder mit umgeht er
ist auch gar nicht Bestandteil
eigentlich der aktuellen bayerischen
Landespolitik dass das jetzt sozusagen
jetzt dadurch mit reinkommt und man
dadurch etwas redet was die Leute
vielleicht auch gar nicht so sehr im
Moment beschäftigt aber in Bezug auf
Hubert Aiwanger jetzt beschäftigen muss
was könnte das für den Fortgang des
Wahlkampfes bedeuten wenn ein Wangen im
Amt Liebe wenn er also wenn er nicht
entlassen wird oder wenn ich zurückgeht
ich glaube
also das hängt einfach jetzt wirklich
vom Fortgang ankommt kommt da noch was
oder kommt da nichts mehr es darf nichts
mehr kommen aber das wir können ja alle
nicht in die Kristallkugel gucken wie
das ist und wir können ja letzten Endes
auch nicht einfach nur aus Gefühl heraus
die für uns die Entscheidung treffen hat
der Aiwanger nur gelogen oder war das
die Wahrheit das ist der Bruder war dass
das nicht wahr stimmt die Version er
hatte
Exemplare im Ranzen weil er sie selber
in die Schule bringen wollte oder hat er
sie zum Schutz seines Bruders
eingesammelt um sie raus da stehen ja
völlig gegensätzliche Behauptungen im
Raum und keiner von uns weiß wie es
wirklich war und ob es rauskommen wird
aber davon hängt ja doch auch ein
bisschen ab wie man das alles zu sehen
hat die Frage eigentlich hatte diese
nazi-aspekte oder antisemitische spekte
oder was auch immer gar nichts in diesem
Wahlkampf zu suchen ja genau und
deswegen glaube ich ist auch der Versuch
solche Linien in den Wahlkampf zu ziehen
eine sehr zweischneidige Sache für
diejenigen die das versuchen in diesem
Fall natürlich dann eben auch die
Süddeutsche Zeitung denn die meisten
Leute werden doch sagen einen Moment mal
wir haben eine sehr sehr schlimme
deutsche Geschichte aber das heißt doch
eigentlich wir können nicht leichtfertig
mit der Nazi Keule umgehen wir können
nicht leichtfertig jemand Etiketten
ankleben oder andere sagen nee gerade
weil wir diese Geschichte haben müssen
wir besonders wachsam sein und schon
beim kleinsten Verdacht und so weiter
ich wäre dafür Zurückhaltung und ich
wäre eher für die Trennung Herr Aiwanger
hat sich im Erding sehr
rechtspopulistisch geäußert mit
Begriffen die wir sonst von Herrn Trump
kennen die auch afd-na sind also es gibt
eine schweigende Mehrheit wir müssen uns
die Demokratie zurückholen das ist
gefährlich weil das ein bestimmten Klang
hat aber nur deshalb immer schon zu
sagen dass sein nazijargon das geht dann
eben auch wieder zu weit naja vielleicht
noch einen Punkt also was der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Freien Wähler
im Landtag
geäußert hat zum Beispiel ich glaube es
war gestern das die die Medien im Grunde
genommen also Vorwurf an die Süddeutsche
Zeitung das Schicksal der Juden
instrumentalisieren würden um einen
Kollegen fertig zu machen das ist nun
wirklich eine hochproblematische Form
der Mobilisierung der eigenen
Wählerschaft anhand dieses Themas und
auch eine Umkehr denn das Flugblatt gibt
es ja also kein Wort zu diesem Flugplatz
erstmal ist sondern gerade diese diese
Kommunikationsstrategie und da zeigt
sich schon etwas oder zeichnet sich
etwas ab was in einem Wahlkampf nicht
stattfinden sollte also das ist schon
ähm eine eine Trennlinie die sollte man
nicht überschreiten
hat ja auch bundespolitische Ambitionen
er würde auch gerne in den Bundestag
gehen wird Bayern verlassen bei dem
Bundestag zu gehen gehört nicht zur
Realität und zur Wahrheit dazu dass
dieser Vorwurf egal was jetzt hier ein
paar Jahren passiert selbst wenn es
jetzt andere verläuft dass dieser vor
warf latent
Nazi zu sein dass ihm das ewige anhängen
wird
der gute Frage ist ja bezieht sich das
jetzt auf Äußerungen
gewisse von Marshall dass er genannt in
Erding wo er diesen AFD sprech
losgelassen hat oder bezieht sich das
jetzt auf diese
Verdachtsberichterstattung über das was
in den Flugplatz steht Michael Wolf
sondern der jüdische Historiker hat ja
gesagt das sei eigentlich gar kein
antisemitisches Flugblatt weil
anisminismus bedeutet Juden werden
verächtlich gemacht sie werden mit dem
Tod bedroht werden umgebracht es wird ja
diese nur diese Folie von Auschwitz
Dachau und so weiter benutzt von Juden
ist in diesem Flugplatz ja gar nicht die
Rede es wird nur dieser nazischargon
benutzt um ähm in Form einer sogenannten
Satire allen anderen die er als Vater
die der Verfasser als Vaterlandsverräter
bezeichnet das gleiche Schicksal an zu
drohen die seinerzeit den Juden im
holocause vielleicht auch noch dazu
sagen in dem Zusammenhang wird ja immer
wieder mal das Wort Jugend Sünde auf das
sozusagen eine lässliche Jugendsünde ist
wer hat keine von uns begangen hat das
die Diskussion in einer Weise belastet
die eigentlich unangemessen war
sozusagen das war ja eigentlich dieses
Flugblatt muss ja noch mal sagen von
einer beispiellosen Niedertracht ist das
ist ja mehr als eine Jugendsünde
es ist einerseits mehr als eine
Jugendsünde aber wenn wir uns auf der
anderen Seite jetzt mal irgendein
Politiker der SPD der CDU der über jeden
Zweifel erhalten er haben ist und der
auch jetzt heute nicht durch
populistische rechtspopulistische Dinge
aufgefallen ist vorstellen dass er
dieses Flugblatt verfasst hätte
dann wäre es glaube ich relativ klar
dass wir sagen würden okay wir lassen
milde verwalten das war eine Jugendsünde
wenn er sich natürlich dann sehr
glaubhaft demütig distanziert hätte wir
haben andere Politiker gehabt wie
Joschka Fischer der hat mal Steine
geworfen und der hat aber eben ist genau
und der hat das sehr glaubwürdig machen
können dass das eben ja seine
jugendünden gewesen sind und ich glaube
er war da sogar noch deutlich älter als
das gemacht hat also ich denke schon wir
sind als Gesellschaft und das finde ich
auch gut zu milde fähig und das ist auch
eine wichtige Eigenschaft aber dann sind
wir ja wieder bei diesem Bericht der Süd
der deutschen Zeitung das war ja genau
der Grund warum die Süddeutsche Zeitung
heute eingestiegen ist um eben diese
Linie wie sehr man das auch immer
kritisieren kann eben an der Stelle zu
zeichnen dass eben er heute nicht
antisemitisch nicht rechtsradikal ist
aber er eben schon recht populistisch
tatsächlich agiert hat und man könnte
das ist jetzt zugegebenermaßen eine
steile These eine wilde Spekulation man
könnte natürlich auch spekulieren hat er
vielleicht eben sich nicht für die
Entschuldigung entschieden weil dann
hätte er wirklich an der Stelle auch ein
gewisser Weise schwach gewirkt er hätte
dann wirklich den Kritikern der
Süddeutschen Zeitung ja wirklich
Entgegenkommen müssen und hat sich dann
eben für den ja Gegenangriff das hat
aber irgendwie im du es ja gerade
gemacht wir haben diesen ja gezeigt das
war dann schon etwas von vielen ihm
vielleicht den ersten Moment gar nicht
erwarten konnte von Mascha sie haben ja
selbst in einem Kommentar zu ähm
Ellwanger genau auf dieses mit zweierlei
Maß messen hingewiesen also Joschka
Fischer haben sie auch erwähnt in ihrem
Kommentar hansmoto auch der für Mauerbau
für Schießbefehl und Wahlfälschung
zuständig war mit zuständig war im
Politik oder der SPD und auch noch
später in der in der PDS Karriere
gemacht hat war ja auch Bundestags
Mitglied
kommt es da immer vor allen Dingen auf
den politischen Standpunkt an
es sollte eben nicht darauf ankommen
aber wir sind inzwischen in einer
Gesellschaft die auch sich so
polarisiert hat dass das eine Lager
immer dem anderen vorwirft es wurde mit
falschen Maßstäben messen und genauso
umgekehrt und natürlich sind das
betrachtungsfragen oder Haltungsfragen
und es ist besorgniserregend für eine
Gesellschaft wie unsere die vom
Austausch lebt und die von der Debatte
lebt wenn sie nicht gemeinsame Maßstäbe
finden kann das das versuchte ich in dem
Kommentar zu schreiben und natürlich
eben dieses Land hat eine Tradition dass
es sich gesamte Biografien anschaut und
das ist das entscheidende wenn man in
den letzten 10 15 20 Jahren keine großen
Anlässe gegeben hat an der Loyalität zur
Demokratie zum Rechtsstaat zu zweifeln
dann ist es halt
dann liegt es quer im Raum wenn man
diese Taten aus der Jugend rausholt ich
habe mit Absicht den Begriff Jugendsünde
nicht verwendet weil der viel zu harmlos
in diesem Kontext klingt weil eben
dieses Pamphlet so und säglich ist aber
wir haben eben bei Leuten wie Joschka
Fischer gesagt ja der hat früher den
Rechtsstaat bekämpft der hat auf am
Boden liegende Polizisten eingeprügelt
davon gibt's Bilder das ist auch nicht
geleugnet aber der Außenminister Joschka
Fischer hat sich zu einem Menschen
entwickelt der die Werte und dieses
Landes glaubwürdig repräsentiert und
verteidigt und deswegen musste er nicht
zurücktreten bei Hans Modrow haben das
vielleicht nicht wegen Hans modero
gemacht sondern weil uns der das Ziel
der deutschen Einheit und der
Eingliederung von Menschen die in einem
anderen politischen System groß geworden
sind und da vielleicht Dinge getan
hätten haben die zwar schwere Verbrechen
sind aber wir wissen ja nicht wie wir in
solchen Situationen gehandelt hätten
also deswegen er hatte nur allerdings
auch kein Regierungsamt Hans Modrow hat
aber obwohl er nachher verurteilt wurde
wegen Wahlfälschung wegen Meineid seine
Parteiämter hat er alle behalten niemand
hat damals in von der PTS verlangt man
müsse ihm den Ehrenvorsitz und so weiter
den solche Ämter Abnehmen nicht also
insofern ich würde auch denken dass
Leute wie Hans modrohr am Ende ihren
Frieden mit der westdeutschen Demokratie
gemacht haben insofern passte das dann
auch wieder aber wenn wir diese Maßstäbe
anlegen dann dürfen wir gar nicht so
sehr fragen was hat Aiwanger als
17-Jähriger gemacht sondern müssen wir
fragen ist das jemand der als
Vize-Regierungschef von Bayern als
Wirtschaftsminister in der Art wie er
die Freien Wähler führt ist das eher
eine eine loyale Art mit der
bundesrepublikanischen Demokratie und
dem Rechtsstaat umzugehen oder weckt er
Zweifel dass er auf der anderen Seite
steht und deswegen also ich persönlich
habe
ich bin jetzt nicht ein Aiwanger
Biograph und habe mir alles angeschaut
aber soweit ich mir das angeschaut habe
muss ich sagen mir ist nichts
untergekommen wo Herr Aiwanger in den
letzten Jahren sich antisemitisch
rechtsradikal nazi-freundlich was auch
immer geäußert hat er hat sich
Rechtspopulist das habe ich ja vorher
auch gerade schon mal gesagt das ist ein
Jargon der erinnert mich an Trump und
die AFD und so weiter und das muss
darüber müssen die bayerischen Fehler
entscheidend weiter sehen auch viele
andere Menschen so es gibt eine
Blitzumfrage der Kollegen von der
Augsburger Allgemeinen heute
veröffentlicht
53% der deutschen also wie gesagt eine
Blitzumfrage halten einen Rücktritt oder
hielten einen Rücktritt von alwanger für
falsch in Bayern sind es sogar 62%, das
ist ein ziemlich eindeutiger Befund
ist diese Diskussion dann eher ein
elitenprojekt oder das ist so ein
bisschen an der Überzeugung auch in der
Stimmung an der Reaktion der
unmittelbaren Reaktion der Bevölkerung
vorbeigeht also es wundert mich nicht
weil genau die Effekte eintreten die
auch beschrieben worden sind also es ist
eine Sache die 36 Jahre zurück und
wahrscheinlich haben viele
in der Bevölkerung und auch von uns mit
17 Jahren mal irgendwas daher geredet
woran man Ungarn erinnert wird das liegt
glaube ich in der Natur der Sache und
ist das noch mal eine andere Kategorie
also die ist durch komponiert bis in die
Jahreszahl erste 88 also die Schiffe ist
klar das ist schon nicht einfach so mal
dahin geschmiert worden egal wer es
jetzt geschrieben hat Aiwanger Bruder
oder eher selber aber ich denke dass die
Anforderungen an die Integrität des
politischen Personals hochzusetzen sind
das ist für die repräsentative
Demokratie ein wichtiger Punkt und dann
ist die Frage wie geht man im Endeffekt
mit diesem Vorwurf um also das ist ja
eine Frage der klausibilität der
Faktizität die man nachweisen kann und
eben auch eine Bewertung wie hat sich
Aiwanger jetzt als Wirtschaftsminister
in dieser für ihn schweren persönlichen
Krise Verhalten und das ist nicht sehr
überzeugend unbeschadeter Tatsache dass
die Äußerungen in den vergangenen Wochen
welche sind die ja nicht nur
populistisch im engeren Sinne sind
sondern die auf die Delegitimierung
demokratischer und
verfassungsinstitutionen Zielen also das
ist die Frage wie bewertet man diese
Person dann insgesamt aber es wundert
mich nicht dass der erste Impuls wenn
man eine Umfrage macht erstmal der ist
dass man sagt naja okay der
Resonanzboden den er in Bayern hat der
ist ja für ihn ja auch durchaus
vorhanden die Freien Wähler von denen
jetzt mal davon ausgehen dass sie in
ihrer mehr zahlen tatsächlich hinter
Hubert Albaner stehen oder die
Sympatisanten oder die sich
beabsichtigen ihn zu wählen am 8 Oktober
was sind das muss man die einordnen in
Bayern die Freien Wähler denn mit dem
Amtsantritt von Hubert Aiwanger als
Landes und Bundesvorsitzender hat sich
ja eine ursprünglich sehr stark auf
kommunales eher so liberal konservative
Spektrum auch so ein bisschen in Distanz
zu CSU doch schon eine eher
hat es eine sozusagen einen Rechtsruck
in der Partei gegeben Albaner ist auch
sehr viel populärer geworden dadurch
dass er auch bundesweit aufgetreten ist
auch bei der Bundestagswahl angetreten
mit den Freien Wählern wie muss man die
Freien Wähler einschätzen auch
vielleicht nicht nur Abgrenzung zur CSU
sondern auch zu AFD also ich würde nicht
bestätigen dass die Freien Wähler
rechtsradikaler oder oder
die sind nicht nach rechts
die Freien Wähler waren immer Verzeihung
ein wilder Haufen sie sagen richtig
konservativer liberaler die einfach
nichts mit der so zu tun haben wollten
in Bayern Fleisch vom Fleisch hätte der
CSU aber wollten halt nicht jedes Jahr
an dieser Ausrichtung hat sich nicht
allzu viel verändert was ich verändert
hat das ist ein Hubert eiwanger
der seit Monaten im Wahlkampfmodus ist
und gemerkt hat dass er mit seiner Art
zu reden wir sagen populistisch das ist
unsere unsere journalistische Form eine
akademische Form aber die Leute auf der
Straße schon gehört wenigstens so dass
ich es auch verstehe
auf diese Art und Weise zu reden das hat
er gemerkt das bringt ihm Wählerstimmen
ein und das will er sich auch nicht
nehmen lassen
ob dahinter ein ein echter Rechtsruck
steht
vermag man von außen schwer zu
beurteilen ich persönlich glaube es
nicht also was waren was man weiß aus
der Forschung zu Freien Wählern ist dass
die Freien Wähler denn Orts oder die
Ortsparteien auf der lokalen Ebene den
Freien Wählern häufig näher stehen in
dem programmatischen Punkten als den
Landes- und bundesverbänden ihre eigenen
Partei also es gibt durchaus so diese
sehr stark lokale Orientierung sie
kommen aber eher aus der sozialen aus
dem sozialen Milieu von kleinen
Unternehmen Mittelstand und so weiter
und so fort und sind eher liberal
konservativ aber auch in anderen
Bundesländern nicht so stark wie in
Bayern aber sie reden da ja auch es gibt
ja wirklich in zwei Bundesländern sind
sie auch sogar in Rheinland-Pfalz
und es gibt in einem anderen Bundesland
wir haben jetzt das Land nicht einfällt
wo es ist dass die da sind also
sozusagen
das einzige Land wo man sagen kann das
hat eine durchgehende
regierungstradition einer Partei gegeben
nicht ganz am Anfang da gab es noch die
Bayernpartei aber das ist andere
Bundesländer haben Regierungswechsel
erlebt also dass die Regierungspartei
eine andere war und das zweite besondere
Punkt mehrere der Leute die bei den
Freien Wählern
prominent sind stammen ja aus der CSU
die sind doch zum Teil ausgetreten und
haben sich sozusagen dort organisiert
weil sie mit dieser Staatspartei CSU
oder mitbekommen haben dass da Dinge
nicht richtig laufen dass man dann
trotzdem nicht wirklich Opposition in
der Partei machen kann das sind glaube
ich zwei bayerische Besonderheiten also
das die CSU immer regiert hat also ist
wir nie in Regierungswechsel bisher
erlebt haben und dass die ob das die
Leute die bei den Freien Wählern sind
erstens das regional Lokale haben aber
eben auch oft nicht eine Welt
anschauliche dezents mit der CSU sondern
mit einem Dissens wie die Herrschaft
ausgeübt wurde und dass sie mit ihrer
Opposition dagegen nicht durchkamen
deswegen musste man sich anders
organisieren und das ist mit freien WLAN
woanders bisschen anders
der Hubert Albaner hat sich ja an der
demokogie gegen den Euro 2012 nicht
beteiligt obwohl er ausgefordert worden
ist jetzt sagt man ja auch dass der
hättest du das damals gemacht dann geht
es nicht die AFD als die Alternative
sondern die Freien Wähler das heißt das
wäre ja sozusagen der Gegenbeweis dass
er eigentlich ja sich von dieser
Radikalisierung auch distanziert in
manchen Punkten ja also es ist natürlich
im Auftreten jemand der Windkraftanlagen
in Bayern
hat auch durchaus ab und zu eine
ökologische Komponente die ja auch
fördert als Wirtschaftsminister es ist
nicht alles schwarz-weiß in der in dem
Auftreten von Aiwanger und das
ökologische und das konservative
verbinden sich auch in dieser Person in
Teilen zumindest also von daher aber zu
sagen ja wenn eiwanger jetzt 20.12 sich
anders verhalten hätte gibt sie AFD
nicht das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu
schlicht argumentiert so weit würde ich
nicht gehen aber
Resultat also die programmatische
Bandbreite ist dann eben doch manchmal
etwas
breiter gleichzeitig ist aber das
Auftreten eines das in den vergangenen
Monaten eben doch
diese parteienkritik umgewandelt hat in
eine Delegitimierung auch der
verfassungsinstitution das ist schon ein
Problem das ist ja noch eine zweite
Person wir haben sie schon angesprochen
im
politischen Zielfernrohr im Moment
Markus Söder der jetzt auch das haben
wir schon angesprochen wie diesen 25
Fragenkatalog
versucht hat zwar Zeit zu gewinnen aber
er braucht ja auch irgendeine Begründung
möglicherweise sich von Albaner zu
trennen oder eben auch nicht war das
eine gute Idee sie haben gesagt er hat
ja den guten performt an diesem Tag aber
die gerade mit dieser was kann da
eigentlich rauskommen vor allen Dingen
weil ja möglicherweise wieder
fragenkatalogie täglich erweitert werden
muss
also Markus Söder performt eigentlich
immer gut ist mein Eindruck aber um
jetzt auf Ihre Frage einzugehen er hat
eben damit es geschafft er hat eine
Situation jetzt geschaffen die zu einem
in der Entscheidung kulminiert nämlich
entweder pro oder contra Albaner und das
hatte eben mit diesem 25 Fragen
tatsächlich geschafft aber ich glaube
ähm weil ja auch gerade am Ende die
Entscheidung bei Söder liegt also wir
können uns ja jetzt ganz viel darüber
diskutieren wie eiwanger sich
entscheidet das ist das Verhalten wir
welche Fehler er macht oder nicht macht
am Ende entscheidet ja Markus Söder ob
er ihn entlässt oder ob er ihn nicht
entlassen wird und ich glaube auch wenn
natürlich jetzt bei Markus Söder erst
die Perspektive auf einen Erfolg der
Landtagswahl gerichtet ist das steht
absolute Mittelpunkt aber man kann
glaube ich diese Situation auch nicht
ganz ohne jetzt die Bundespolitik
betrachten weil Markus Söder hat schon
sicherlich Bunde politische Ambition
über die Landtagswahl hinaus und das
heißt er könnte sicherlich wenn er die
Ambition nicht hätte sehr viel
schmerzfreier jetzt agieren und könnte
viel Kritik auch einfach ausblenden
ähnlich wie Aiwanger das macht aber
daher eben diese bundespolitischen
Ambitionen noch hat muss er das schon im
Blick behalten sonst ist nämlich seine
bundespolitische Karriere dann nach der
Lande im Landtagswahl eben auch zu Ende
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Redaktion ihr Ohr am CSU Gemäuer haben
was steht denn in diesem Fragenkatalog
kann man das ähm
zumindest skizzieren paraphrasieren das
sind die Schotten dicht etwas was auch
die Opposition in Bayern sehr ärgert
weil die natürlich sagen es kann nicht
sein dass die da intern eine
Fragenkatalog aufstellen und dann intern
die beantworten und dann intern
entscheiden ob das jetzt reicht oder
nicht sondern das ganze muss auf dem
Tisch und als Journalist sage ich ich
wünsche mir dass das irgendwann auf dem
Tisch kommt in der haben was fürs erste
nicht ähm aber eigentlich ist die so
oder auch immer ganz verlässlich
was könnte da was können das für Fragen
sein vor allem was für Antworten die wir
nicht schon entweder längst beantwortet
haben
Details da ist
warum er Erinnerungslücken hat wie das
jetzt war mit der mit der Jugendsünde
reden wir ja hat das verfasst hat das
nicht verfasst
warum
hingehalten
im Kopf kann ich nachvollziehen so ist
es bei dem Bayern da hängt man den
eigenen Bruder eine unbedingt hin außer
man will den Hof haben aber ähm
Bauernhof
festhalten auf der einen Seite voller
Aufklärung und volle Transparenz zu
fordern und dann kennen wir nicht mal
die Punkte bei denen Transparenz
gefordert
dazu wenn ich das sagen darf
die spiegelberichterstattung von heute
da kommt ja noch eine ganz neue Facette
dass sich so bestätigt dass 2008
Aiwanger zu Seehofer damals gegangen ist
und gesagt das stimmt es wirklich dass
ein csu-mitarbeiterrat bei mir in der
Schule in meinem Umfeld recherchiert und
Material gegen mich zu geringen und das
war ein Jahr nachdem die CSU die Affäre
pauli hatte mit mit stäuber hatte der
Eimer also offensichtlich Angst auch
ausgeforscht zu werden es gab da
indizienter da muss auch die CSU noch
ein bisschen was aufklären übrigens
Seehofer kann sich nicht ganz gut
erinnern obwohl es nur 15 Jahre
zurückgegangen 35 es hat was Besonderes
wenn der Koalitionsausschuss zu einer
Art Untersuchungsausschuss und der
Ausschuss der Öffentlichkeit
umfunktioniert wird das ist schon ähm
hat schon ein bisschen gewisse
Pikanterie muss ich sagen und Söder
macht sich damit natürlich auch ständige
hierher gegenüber den freien Wäldern
innerhalb der Koalition und das ist bei
Koalitionspartnern schon was sehr
besonderes gemacht
wir wollen nicht aufhören wenn es am
schönsten wird im Gespräch sind wir
müssen aufhören so am schönsten wird
leider hier sind am Ende ich bedanke
mich bei Sabine Kropp bei Alexander kein
bei Olaf Hoffmann bei Christoph von
Marschall die ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer nächste aktuelle Phoenix
gesprächsendung am kommenden Montag
unter den Linden 22 oder 15 Mutter wird
von Thomas Becker aktuell ist bei
Phoenix der Tag mit ihnen ist mit
aktuellen von Tag lohnt sich bleiben Sie
bei uns
[Musik]